start off as like a band of banded
brothers like you know a handful of
people in a shed yeah a radiator is a
game-changing expense a good
game-changing addition to the business
and now jim shark is a billion plus a
dollar company you're the new ceo of it
like how many employees do you do you
know uh we're just over 700 700 and you
sell all of the world with offices all
around the world
that's going to feel pretty wild like
it's cool it's cool honestly i still
walk into the hq so we've got a gorgeous
hq and there's the sort of the big logo
on the front over the road we've got our
lifting club we've got like a gym
manufacturing facility studios i do walk
in and
like i do still get goosebumps because
it's it's such an amazing place and
there's a buzz like you've got to visit
because as soon as you walk in the door
there's a buzz there and everyone's
lovely everyone's pulling in the same
direction everyone really understands
why we do what we do
everyone understands the area that they
sort of fit in with that sort of wider
plan
it's it's such a lovely place to be
so
it's interesting you say that like
everyone's putting in the same direction
because i think i feel like
this is an issue we're having as we
expanded from three people to 12 people
whereby i'm now having starting to do
things like defining our vision and
where we want to be in x number of years
and kpis and goals and all this stuff
that in the past i would have thought
this is all just corporate [ __ ] like
who cares about any of that
um
presumably like like
what was your journey through kind of
being more businessy about it so what
you're going through yeah so we did that
i used to hate the word corporate yep
and you're going through for reading
between the lines what i actually think
is the most difficult change i think
this is one of the most difficult things
for any entrepreneur or business person
and by the way not even owning your own
business if you're
running or working in a great business
it's so difficult to sort of distribute
that control and
i think those that can do that then
after that it's not plain sailing but if
you've then done that it's like you know
it's like a muscle memory right if you
continue to do that i think scaling
becomes so much easier
um i'll give you so my sort of breakdown
i sort of break it down into three areas
and i think every great business person
needs to reinvent themselves over and
over again so you can't become too like
tied in or emotionally attached to sort
of i'm going to say who you are in many
respects so at the start i found
i had a great creative vision i didn't
exist i had a great idea where i wanted
us to be and i i felt like i dragged the
business to where i wanted us to be and
that sounds a bit sort of direct but you
know it could be having a great creative
vision it could be great at knowing
products it could be great at whatever
it is but
you because you tend to be a one-man
band or there's not many people involved
you just do what the hell you want when
you want and it's very instinctive
now you'll then get to a stage where
you've got people around you it might be
five people it might be 10 people it
might be 30 people
and an instinctive way of running things
it's still great but you can't just do
things on a whim because you fancy you
have to then learn to work in a team and
i don't mean when i say in a team i mean
you are part of the team and anyone
that's managed a team knows that the
team doesn't work for you you work for
them and you need to make sure that
you're really understanding how to work
with each different type of people's
person so yeah some people will love to
be organized and they will love lots of
different catch-ups and you know some
people will be highly creative some
people will be highly logical some
people you'll have to spend six weeks
trying to buy them into a new new idea
some people have to spend six seconds
and it's about learning how to work with
all these different people so you've
gone from dragging the business to where
you wanted it to be learning to work
with new people and then that's it
sounds like to a degree what you're
going through slash the next stage which
is like okay you know how to work with
people
how do we galvanize them around a vision
or a mission how do we make them
understand where they fit in with that
how do we make them understand that
you know the team that we're working
with touch what is greater than the sum
of its parts and really understanding
how to articulate yourself and your
vision um
and essentially learning how to inspire
people and i think that's again it's
very tough and
i hear people a lot of the time saying
like
oh you know
one facet of their personality that's
just me what am i like i'm a bit
unorganized well
when you're at that level there's not
there's no excuse for being an organizer
like yes i am an organized but you do
something about it you either fix it
yourself or you build the team in a way
that negates that weakness does that
make sense
it's um i think it gets a bit more
serious at that point and yeah you have
to learn new skills and trust that's why
i love the job so much and feel like
i've got the best job in the world
because you're constantly learning new
things and constantly reinventing
yourself